Kylie Jenner is over Rob Kardashian's
engagement to blac Chyna after the
initial shock of Rob's relationship to
her boyfriend Tyga's ex Rob is dating
someone that has kind of had a bad
history with my family the 18 year old
reality star has since met up with China
at least once and now et has learned
she's in a much better place a source
exclusively tells et Kylie did find it
tough to accept the two were dating but
quote she sees how happy he is and all
she wants is for him to be happy the
general consensus in the house is praise
China don't go they finally got the
brother they always knew back and the
Kardashian clan is finally back together
on TV our source adds that Rob is
officially filming the reality series
full time again and that even China will
appear in future episodes Kris and Kylie
Jenner aren't the only ladies in Rob's
life who have a change of heart about
his fiance according to our source the
entire family is so happy for him and
are over the initial shock of their
relationship meanwhile Kylie shocked us
by making her singing debut on an
explicit remix to the children's theme
song of Mister Rogers neighborhood
Jordan
a B Kylie should leave the rapping to
her boyfriend
should let me finish baby let you finish
later